[Musique]
délégués sont en ce moment même avec
kennedy jack ou bob s'est dit bon sang
mais cet hôtel est infesté quoi bonjour
je vous permettez que je vous pose une
question ligne complètement perdu la
tête
personne ne l'est on a besoin des états
du sud n'a aucun pouvoir dans la dce
président c'est l'homme qui donne du
pouvoir la fonction je veux qu'on
affiche de bons résultats sur les droits
civiques dès le départ peut-être qu'ils
écouteront un sudiste qui est de notre
côté qu'est ce qui te dit qu'il est de
notre côté
lesquels dire vraiment une dent contre
toi c'est sûrement pas ces gamins de
leurs vaart qui vont nous dire comment
diriger l'état de géorgie vous allez
perdre le soutien de vos partisans les
plus fidèles
si je me présente comme président en 68
il faudra que tout le monde même fermé
la porte
comment pourrait-on ne pas l'aimer
martin luther king écrit des lettres
depuis sa prison c'est une honte pour
notre pays si vous faites voter les
droits civiques maintenant ça ne
deviendra jamais une loi est ce qu'on
attend pour le faire
[Musique]
un nouveau dirigeant à nrg l'américain
enfin un président sudiste
apparemment vous ne perdez pas de temps
excusez moi ça ne se passe pas du tout
comme dans mon rêve
kennedy avait de belles et grandes cités
maintenant le pays a besoin d'un homme
[Musique]
qui les réalise
il n'y aura pas le moindre compromis
nous voulons que l'espoir du président
kennedy de vienne
une réalité
[Musique]
ce sera le symbole de ton mandat
présidentiel c'est tout ce que je
souhaite
ok